So continuous integration just means
that whenever you check in new code,
it gets integrated, and built.
But seriously we're not
going to do that by hand.
Running the compiler and
test suite is a job for a program.
And no surprise there are a lot
of pieces of software to do this.
One of the most popular ones is Jenkins.
It's an open source
project written in Java.
You have to host it yourself.
There are also several
hosted CI solutions.
Like Travis CI and Circle CI and others.
All of them work on the same principals.
The CI system,
watches a code repo or branch.
What it is looking for
is new commits written by developers.
When a new commit occurs the CI
systems grabs the new commit and
spawns a build process.
The build process runs and builds things
such as compiled binaries or data files.
Once the build is successfully complete,
the CI system then spawns tests that
can be run on the build artifacts and
then it reports the results
back to the developer.
Now, since most of the hosted CI
solutions require subscription, for
the next part of this course,
you will be setting up and
using your own Jenkins server